the zuckerberg trap that's the focus of
tonight's angle
facebook's internal research is aware
that there are a variety of problems
facing children on instagram they know
that severe harm is happening to
children kids kids who are bullied on
instagram the bullying follows them home
it follows them into their bedrooms
facebook's own research is aware that
children express feelings of loneliness
and struggling with these things i don't
understand how facebook can know all
these things and not
escalate it to someone like congress for
help and support in navigating these
problems appearing on appearing on 60
minutes and in the hearings on the hill
well former facebook employee francis
haugen
claimed that the social media giant was
knowingly hurting kids through its
algorithms and posted content now what's
worse she alleged the company knew about
it and chose to do nothing to stop it
now all of a sudden
the beast first conceived at harvard by
boy wonder mark zuckerberg was getting
hit by a bipartisan onslaught of outrage
we know
from what we have learned from her
that this is helping us build bipartisan
support facebook has put profits ahead
of people my message for mark zuckerberg
your time of invading our privacy
promoting toxic content and preying on
children and teens is over
hmm
does no one else think the timing of
this is just a little too convenient
biden's on the ropes and the democrats
are barreling toward a brutal beatdown
in the midterms
could this just be a clever way to rev
up the speech police against alternative
points of view ahead of the election
all under the guise of protecting the
children the reconciliation bill was a
culmination of my
service in congress because it was about
the children the children the children
the children
they love citing the children well let's
begin with one basic fact
the left doesn't care if the culture or
big business spreads content that's not
appropriate for children they never have
they literally do not care in fact for
decades liberals have defended even
celebrated cultural and political forces
that harm children
porn drugs gambling gender bending
school shutdowns mask mandates and of
course their holy grail of abortion
democrats support all of it
now some on the left would prefer if we
didn't even have children
a new york magazine columnist named
emily holloman recently called the
decision to have children an essentially
selfish one done for fulfillment or
self-betterment or boredom or peer
pressure
we should pray for her because she knows
not what she says
but the point is after all they've done
to damage our children and steal their
innocence
we're supposed to trust them on the
facebook and instagram issue
color me skeptical
we've known for many years that parents
should keep their kids off smartphones
for as long as possible
we need to put our own phones down
myself included and do the hard job of
parenting in this very messed up world
conservative parents have led the charge
on these issues for as long as i can
remember
but now suddenly people like far left
senator ed markey agrees with staunch
republican marsha blackburn
and we're supposed to think that he's
trustworthy
not so fast
the fact is republicans may be walking
straight into a trap
the left's real beef with facebook has
nothing to do with the children the kids
are on tick tock aren't they
the left doesn't like facebook because
facebook has refused to suppress all
conservative speech that's it
the left has decided to drive
conservatives off of the internet and
they're afraid facebook won't be
sufficiently loyal to their plans
they actually got away with banning the
former president of the united states
and that's not enough power for the
democrats
they're that afraid of voters in free
speech think about that for a minute
now this is why globalists don't mind
china being in charge frankly because if
they could some of these really
hard-line democrats would ban all
dissenting opinions on social media and
just like china they'd probably call it
something like a threat to the social
order or a threat to security or a
threat to
overall community or harmony
now this all makes sense if your goal is
to maintain power by any means necessary
and let's face it that's all they care
about
facebook could promote live sex acts and
how to hunt a cr on a christian
instructionals
and the left would take their side but
because there's still some conservatives
on facebook some conservatives
the left wants to shut it down
democrats have seized upon the current
facebook scandal as an opportunity to
silence conservatives for good
you know that the insurrection occurred
january 6 do you think that facebook
turned off the safeguards because they
were costing the company money facebook
changed those safety defaults in the
run-up to the election because they knew
they were dangerous
and because they wanted that growth back
they wanted the acceleration of the
platform back after the election they
they returned to their original defaults
and the fact that they had to break the
glass on january 6th and turn them back
on
i think that's deeply problematic agree
if democrats had a super majority they
wouldn't work with republicans at all on
these issues they just passed maybe
legislation that has the effect of
silencing all dissenting speech it would
be directed broadly across all media and
online platforms but cloaked in terms
again of protecting national security or
their new favorite preventing domestic
terrorism
they would pack the courts to approve
that legislation and your freedom of
speech and freedom that generations of
americans have fought to preserve would
be gone
that's their real goal
a land where we're silenced
and theirs are the only voices
heard but they're willing to get there
they take a little bit of time to get
there so they'll use the bipartisan dust
kicked up by one whistleblower as
another nudge toward government control
of political speech
although they dispute the
whistleblower's claims facebook
responded by inviting government
regulation
saying we need to create standard rules
for the internet it's time for congress
to act
well kind of makes perfect sense
remember zuckerberg himself was heavily
and personally coordinating with liberal
activists and poured hundreds of
millions of dollars into local election
offices in places like pennsylvania
and after zuckerberg was mercilessly
scorned by the left for not silencing
trump in 2016
he kind of tried to make it up to his
political comrades rads by keeping
trump's reach limited
prediction
this is not going to end well for
conservatives who want to challenge the
left
how do i know this
look who's licking their chops at the
prospect of facebook regulation
facebook ought to be seriously regulated
it is a news source for a vast part of
our country today if it continues the
way it continues
we're going to have january 6 multiple
multiple times it allows lies to be
spread unchecked just like the big lie
was spread around the world in large
part because of social media
and none of it is true we should not
allow those things in our society
i do like the sweater though and what
about the whistleblower herself who is
she
what's her motivation for coming forward
she says she agreed to take the job only
if she could work against misinformation
but after this past election there was a
turning point
they
told us we're dissolving civic integrity
like they basically said oh good we made
it through the election there wasn't
riots
fast forward a couple months we got the
insurrection
and
when they got rid of civic integrity it
was the moment where i was like
i don't trust that they're willing to
actually invest what needs to be
invested to keep facebook from being
dangerous
the woman's a total ideologue sorry
those comments made my spidey senses
activated
republicans ought to be very very
careful about how to proceed here
the left can't be trusted on this issue
and the gop may end up building a trap
that will block conservative speech for
years to come
just look what the biden justice
department is already doing to
intimidate parents we talked about this
last night from attending school board
meetings and expressing their outrage at
the propaganda being taught in public
schools
remember when biden told us that the
justice department would be independent
what a joke that is
these days the doj is just another
branch of the dnc
because the liberal weaklings at the
national school board association don't
want to face criticism for their
horrible policies
they're calling on the doj to
criminalize their political opposition
the only speech they really want to
protect is when you nod in agreement
with every school decision these petty
bureaucrats make
you're using the fbi to intervene in
school board meetings tell me where the
line is with parents expressing their
concerns
waiting for hours when and if a
situation turns to violence it's the job
of the justice department and local law
enforcement to address that the attorney
general's memorandum simply
asks the fbi
and their counterparts to ensure that
state and local law enforcement has an
open line of communication
to report threats
there's so much nonsense in her
statement i don't know where to begin
the fbi exists to investigate whether
parents getting mad at a school board
meeting
rises to the level of intimidation or
harassment that's now a federal matter
think about all the threats facing
america from transnational criminal
syndicates ccp cyber crimes and open
borders and the fbi has time to zero in
on what like a 45 year old mom
complaining about her son's sophomore
english reading list
the only ones guilty of intimidation
here are sitting behind the big desks at
the doj
just thank god that mitch mcconnell and
thank god for him that merrick garland
isn't sitting on the supreme court today
and by the way we just learned tonight
that the defense department is about to
turn the screws on its own ranks
subjecting them to continuous vetting
supposedly to stop extremists within the
military and other insider threats
and this will include surveillance of
social media postings for starters
we warned you last year that the left
has changed since the days of clinton
and obama
as the pain of their policy sinks in
they've just given up altogether trying
to win rhetorically uh the voters over
they're not going to do that anymore
it's impossible
so in their desperation they now believe
force compliance is the only way to go
and the silencing of conservatives the
only way forward
god help any republican who would assist
them
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else